OK, so they say, what's your leadership style?
This is what I would say.
Well, I don't have one single leadership style.
Different situations require different handling.
And in the past, I've had to adopt, on occasion,...
...a very autocratic, authoritarian leadership style for some situations...
...because that's what was needed.
But my default leadership style, if I have one,...
...is more of a consultative leadership style...
...where I, especially if I have good employees,...
...I consult individually with a lot of my employees to get their two cents on the situation...
...and what they feel is the right course of action...
...just to sort of incorporate that into my decision.
And also in the past, I've had to adopt a participative leadership style,...
...where you get everybody together and you hammer it out.
You get everybody's opinion on it and it kind of goes back and forth...
...and that tends to work very well if you know it's a very complex decision...
...that affects everybody in multiple ways.
You know, so that's something that I've employed on occasion.